on va revenir sur toute l'actualité vous
avez vu les champ antisémites dans le
métro les 8 mineurs de 11 à 16 ans ont
été interpellés ça c'était dans dans
l'actualité on va on va voir on vaevoir
cette vidéo regardez vous avez vu
ça
grand les grandm on est des nazis on est
fier voilà alors donc euh ils ont été
interpellés on a appris que 8 mineurs
âgé de 11 à 16 ans seulement avaient été
interpellé par les forces de l'ordre
c'est c'est quoi pour pour vous on fait
quoi avec ce ce ce genre d'individuah
d'abord je pense que au-delà de de des
propos ignobles je pense qu'on condamne
tous il y a je pense une une une une
bêtise en fait une inculture et une
méconnaissance de ce qu'est l'histoire
chez les jeunes génération et là faut
peut-être s'intéresser sur le le boulot
de l'école qui à mon sens passe plus de
temps aujourd'hui à enseigner la
repentance à à expliquer que notre
histoire nationale n'a pas toujours été
glorieuse que on a que la colonisation a
été le crime des crimes plutôt que de
valoriser les bons côtés de l'histoire
de France et de donner la France à aimer
et de donner la France à chérir dè
l'école mais quand vous avez aujourd'hui
dans le paysage politique et donc dans
le paysage médiatique une partie de
l'hémicycle et une partie des gens qui
sont écoutés des gens comme Jean-Luc
Mélenchon qui considèrent au fond que ce
qui s'est passé en Israël c'est des
actes de résistance moi je pense que
c'est du terrorisme je pense que quand
on rentre dans un état qu'on tire sur
des populations civiles qu'on met des
bébés dans des fours qu'on kidnappe des
femmes des enfants et des vieillards et
qu'on est capable de faire la pire
barbarie qui soit c'est pas de la
résistance c'est du terrorisme et quand
vous avez des gens qui sont écoutés
aussi parmi les jeunes parce que
Jean-Luc Mélenchon vous regardez son
nombre d'abonnés TikTok je crois qu'il
est encore un peu devant moi d'ailleurs
sur TikTok euh il a un un un impact chez
les jeunes et donc quand on tient des
propos comme ça on est irresponsable on
a aussi une responsabilité morale dans
ce type de on va venir sur Jean-Luc
Mélenchon et et David guireot dans un
instant juste quand Emmanuel Macron
appelle à un cess le fa Gaza est-ce que
vous êtes d'accord avec lui non parce
que quand on dit cesser le feu ça veut
dire qu'on a en droit international deux
armées régulières qui s'affrontent au
passage Emmanuel Macron qui en fait est
capable de dire systématiquement tout le
contraire de tout avec toujours la
conviction d'avoir raison euh euh change
d'Ave toutes les 24 heures c'est que 24
heures avant il nous dit qu'il faut
anéantir le Hamas ce que partage une
majorité de Français et je crois une
majorité de de gens et 24 heures après
il nous dit faut un cesser le feu quand
on dit cesser le feu en droit
international ça veut dire qu'on a deux
armées régulières qui se battent il y a
pas deux armées régulières qui se
battent on a une armée d'un pays
démocratique qui a une réponse qui est
légitime sur le fond et qui doit sur la
forme être la plus ciblée possible pour
protéger les populations civiles et pour
protéger les innocents qui fait face à
une à une à une organisation terroriste
le Hamas n'est pas une armé c'est une
organisation terroriste quand vous avez
vu que Emmanuel Macron vous a taclé il
dit ceux qui prétendent soutenir no
compatriotes de confession juives en
confondant le rejet des musulmans et le
soutien des Juifs lui répond non mais je
ça c'est des anathèmes en fait
c'est-à-dire sur le fond c'est quoi sa
réponse sur le fond moi je vais vous
dire je pense qu'il y a beaucoup de
Français de confession musulmanes qui
sont tout aussi indignés que moi de ce
qui s'est passé le 7 octobre en Israël
et ça serait bien qu'on puisse leur
donner la parole et qu'on puisse aussi
les entendre et je peux vous dire que
moi en sc saintis j'ai aussi grandi avec
beaucoup de Français de confession
musulmane qui ont fuit l'islamisme
notamment l'islamisme d'Algérie du GA
dans les années 90 et qui aujourd'hui
disent quoi ils disent l'islamisme qu'on
a fuit de notre pays dans les années 90
qui nous a fait faire nore terre nos
enfants nos racines notre pays notre
famille on est en train de le retrouver
aujourd'hui en France pourquoi est-ce
que quand il y a des attentats par
exemple en Tunisie on ferme les mosquées
radicales pourquoi est-ce que les Frères
musulmans qui sont une officine qui ont
PES ouvertes aujourd'hui dans la
République française sont considérés aux
Émirats arabes unis comme une
organisation terroriste et on on leur
déroule aujourd'hui le tapis rouge en
France donc je pense qu'il faut
maintenant avoir une politique à l'égard
de tous ceux qui défient la République
française qui soit beaucoup plus dur et
je pense qu'on doit rendre la France
invivable pour ceux qui la détestent
pour pouvoir protéger tous ceux qui
veulent pouvoir vivre en paix en France
qu que soitir juste une compile de ce
qui se passe à Gaza vous allez dire ce
que vous en pensez
[Musique]
regardez
الم الصفي حيث لا يمكن اجراء
ج الكامل حيث لا
يجد يوم عن يومزيد الوضع ماساه صعبه ج
يعني وكلمه صعبه قليله بالنسبه للوضع
بنعيشه بي نشتري ما في انا اليوم حيت
الساعه 5ص الفجر ورحت على المخابز ولق
المخابز كلها مقفله لانه لا يوجد طحين ولا
ا
voilàce
que comment vous réagissez à
ça la guerre est un drame elle est un
drame pour ceux qui la font elle est un
drame pour ceux qui la subissent
maintenant qui est responsable de cette
situation qui est responsable des
roquettes qui tombent aujourd'hui sur la
ville de Gaza c'est le Hamas c'est le
Hamas qui précisément utilise est-ce que
c'est vrai que ils on sal a voulu livrer
300 l de carburant et que ils sont pas
arrivés parce je je suis pas je n'ai
aucune information à ce sujet je pense
qu'il faut être l'information c'est
aussi un enjeu en T gu fa être très
prudent sur les mais mais qui utilise
aujourd'hui les les les bâtiments civils
les écoles les mosquées les hôpitaux
comme des boucliers humains qui met ses
quartiers généraux sous les mosquées les
écoles les hôpitaux h ce qu'on voit
c'est qu'il y a des civils qui sont pris
qui sont pris dans dans une guerre voilà
et qui qui qui qui qui vivent des
moments très compliqués aussi vous vous
évidemment voilà vous mais non mais
attendez bien sûr et c'est pour ça que
je crois que le rôle de la France c'est
d'avoir une position qui soit une
position raisonnable une position
constante c'est de faire tout le
contraire de ce que fait Emmanuel Macron
c'estàdire de changer la vie toutes les
24 heures moi j'ai voté au Parlement
européen en faveur de pausees
humanitaires je pense qu'il faut des
pauses humanitaires pour permettre
justement au civil d'être le plus à
l'abri possible et j'ai dit depuis le
départ que la réponse d'Israël qui est
légitime sur le fond elle doit être le
plus ciblé possible pour protéger les
populations innocentes mais je n'oublie
pas de rappeler que ceux qui sont
responsables de ces attaques c'est le
Hamas on n'est pas là entre deux armées
on a une armée d'un État démocratique et
en face une organisation terroriste qui
envoie non pas des soldats combattre
mais des soldats prêts à mourir et faire
le jih ne qualifie pas le Hamas de de
groupes terroristes vous lui répondez
non mais Jean-Luc Mélenchon la France
insoumise pourrait s'appeler la France
islamiste c'est que Monsieur Mélenchon
il épouse toutes les thèses des
fondamentalistes islamistes quand on a
une députée madame obono qui est membre
de la France insoumise qui euh euh
s'exprime en disant que le Hamas n'est
pas une organisation terroriste mais un
mouvement de résistance on a tout dit le
rêve de Jean-Luc Mélenchon c'est et
c'est très irrespectueux pour eux
d'ailleurs il pens que en étant le plus
le plus tolérant à l'égard du terrorisme
le plus tolérant à l'égard de
l'idéologie islamiste il pourrait avoir
le vote des Français de confessions
musulmanes dans les bonli donc le plus
cynique dans cette affaire c'est lui et
c'est son mouvement qui je crois a perdu
toute forme d'honneur et qui qui est
très irresponsable sur la forme vous
vous souvenez que pendant les émeutes au
mois de juillet Monsieur Mélenchon avait
refusé d'appeler au calme il avait
attendu 3 jours pour demander simplement
de ne pas euh attaquer les bibliothèques
ou les les centres documentaires et moi
ce qui m'a frappé dans la manifestation
d'hier c'est que quand en fait c'est pas
les amis de Monsieur Mélenchon qui
organiseent des manifestations ça se
passe bien il y a pas de slogan antiflic
il y a pas de casse il y a pas d'abribus
dégradé il y a pas de policiers qui sont
pris à partir les cafés peuvent
continuer d'être ouverts et c'est ça au
fond la différence entre des gens qui
sont responsables qui sont sains et des
gens qui sont des incendiaires et qui
sont représent un danger pour la
République française on voir David Guer
il était en Tunisie ce vendredi il a
fait énormément parler de lui ça fait
une grosse grosse polémique c'était une
conférence intitulée peut-on encore
défendre les Palestiniens en France
regardez et vous me dites ce que vous en
pensez regardez les le bébé dans le
four rendez-vous compte quand même que
les médias diffusent ces informations il
y a aucun mculp moi je suis sûr qu'il y
en aura un dans un ou 2 ans quand ça
sera un petit peu passé que ça coûtera
pas cher en fait boliquement
politiquement économiquement de dire on
a fauté ah vraiment c'était c'était pas
top mais en attendant il retransmettre
ces éléments là le bébé dans le four ça
a été fait en effet par
Israël
la maman est ventrée ça a été fait c'est
vrai par
Israël alors Monsieur guireot le
porte-parole du Hamas que ce qu'il dit
c'est la propagande des terroriste
islamiste du Hamas qu'on massacré des
civils et j'espère que Monsieur guirud
sera cette semaine à l'Assemblée
nationale quand madame Bron Pivet va
diffuser les 43 minutes d'images qui qui
ont été récupéré par l'armée israélienne
et qui vont être diffusé des images des
massacres moi je vais vous dire je les
ai on me les a envoyé les images
massacre je les ai regardé parce que je
pense qu'il faut voir ce qui se passe il
faut voir ce dont sont capablebles les
envoyer également des gens aujourd'hui
c'est pas un choc de civilisation entre
les musulmans les Juifs les Chrétiens
c'est un un choc des mondes entre la
civilisation et la barbarie parce que ce
que font ces gens c'est de la barbarie
et Monsieur guireot voyez il il joue la
l'incendiaire depuis son salon c'est
queil est dans son salon il est dans des
salons feutrés là partout je sais pas où
il est en vacances en Tunisie et il joue
en fait à alimenter le conflit mais
c'est pas monsieur guireud qui va aller
en première ligne pour aller défendre
mais moi j'invite à faire ça si si s'il
veut défendre la population à Gaza s'il
veut défendre les terroristes du Hamas
et bien qu' qu'il aille sur place et qui
soit courageux au point d'aller au bout
et là je pense qu'il y aura un peu moins
de monde à l'aéroport alors ou non David
guireot c'est inacceptable en plus il se
trompent il impute à Israël les
massacres des camps de Sabra et Chatila
c'était des des fallanges
chrétien voilà il voilà bon il se
trompent mais moi j'ai j'ai j'ai une
question à vous poser là vous venez de
dire qu'il aille là-bas pour voir les
populations palestiniennes et le Hamas
en fait vous mêlez toujours les deux
quand le président de la République
appelle à un cesser le feu c'est pour
protéger les populations palest
et arrêter le massacre des populations
palestiniennes de Gaza ça vous n'en
voulez pas en tant commomme d'état vous
ne voulez pas de ça non mais en tant
qu'omme d'État je connais le droit de la
guerre et le cesser le feu en droit de
la guerre c'est l'interruption des
combats entre deux armées ce qu'il faut
c'est des pauses humanitaires pour
permettre à la population de Gaza d'être
ravitaillé mais je peux vous dire que
votre cess le feu il fait qu'un seul
ravi c'est le Hamas parce que le Hamas
il attend qu'une chose c'est que les
frappes israéliennes et l'intervention
de tsal cesse pour pouvoir se
ravitailler pour pouvoir faire rentrer
de l'argent dans Gaza pour pouvoir faire
rentrer des munitions des armes encore
plus puissantes pour mener l'offensive
contre Israël moi je n'ai aucune forme
de tolérance à l'égard du du Hamas donc
on peut se disputer sur les mots que je
reproche à emuel est-ce que vous
condamnez le massacre des populations
civil de Gaza oui ou non je l'ai dit
depuis le départ la réponse israélienne
doit être le plus ciblée possible
maintenant ce que je condamne moi à la
rigueur ça n'a aucun impact moi ce que
je ce que je souhaite faire comme
responsable politique français c'est
protéger mes compatriotes et protéger
mes concitoyens de l'importation sur le
sol français de ce conflit et de dire à
mes concitoyens que l'idéologie du Hamas
elle est déjà sur le territoire de la
République française et encore une fois
c'est ce que je vous disais tout à
l'heure demander à nos compatriotes de
confession juives de quoi ils ont peur
aujourd'hui ils ont peur non pas là-bas
mais ici concrètement dans leur immeuble
dans leur cage d'escalier et et chez eux
maintenant vous savez il faut beaucoup
de modestie sur cette situation c'est
pas nous sur le plateau qui allons
résoudre un conflit qui dure depuis 70
ans sur lequel toutes les grandes
puissances se sont cassé les dents et
toutes les initiatives de paix qui ont
été menées y compris par les grandes
puissances et notamment les accords de
d'Oslo au début des années 90 euh ont
échoué et Raymond Haron qui disait
l'histoire est tragique disait aussi
qu'il y a parfois le père des relations
internationales disait parfois qu'il y a
certains conflits dans le monde qui sont
inexpiable et je pense que celui-ci en
tout cas doit nous appeler à beaucoup de
modestie jeordan mardella